i think a lot of films are too clever
for their own good because they're
they're just twisting and turning the
plot in violation of the character and
you never want to do that because the
moment the audience distances from the
character you've lost them
how do you build a character from
scratch
well it can come from a lot of places
uh idea what i do is i keep a list of
people that i've known in my life and
and actors that i love all of whom are
very distinctive and have different ways
of talking
and every time i write a script i cast
it with people who are very distinctive
in my mind in some cases it's actors i'm
going to
be working with so for doug jones and
bob carter and mira furlin
and bill mummy i wrote those roles for
them for space command um but in some
cases it might be an actor that i'm not
going to get like for instance i wrote a
script called future to space and the
template i used for the lead was ed
harris in the abyss
because it was a great character and a
great voice like it seemed very clearly
in my mind so i knew that ed harris
wasn't going to play that role he's too
old for that role now for one thing but
but it made the character very real very
alive to me
and um
so you just make sure that nobody is
just flat nobody's just there for
exposition
you never i don't tend to describe the
physicality of a character because often
you might have something in mind but
there might be an actor who doesn't look
a thing like that who's great
and you don't want to limit it and um
and i also very much want diversity in
my in my cast asian black different
countries
as
more the better you know and uh so
that's also part of the part of the
design i cast a lot of actors from
restaurants i eat at the waiters are all
the waiters and waitresses are all
actors and actresses and i'll if i find
someone who's
good or who intrigues me i'll say send
me your reel and i'll i'll cast them
yeah i've done that a lot
that's great i like that yeah and also
too you can see how on they are yes
there's a restaurant called granville in
the valley and there was a young actor
who looked exactly like he could be the
son
of ethan mcdowell who plays jack kemmer
the lead in space command and he was an
actor and i and i cast him he's he's in
the bonus episode and he's great he does
a great job so i'm gonna he'll be in
more episodes coming up
what mistakes do new writers make in
writing characters
new writers make a lot of mistakes in
writing characters usually the biggest
mistake is they're just flat they all
sound alike and they just are saying
exactly what they're thinking in real
life people don't say what they're
thinking generally
they might say what they're thinking
directly in an argument but often not
not even then
so
you want to think about how people
really talk and also remember that a
script is not
a representation of real life it's like
a 120 page haiku
and it's so it's it's an it's an
illusion of reality but it isn't reality
and so often the lines have to be a lot
briefer and a lot punchier
but i always like to have characters who
talk differently from each other who are
very different in their outlooks their
world view
also
a mistake many writers make not just in
the beginning of the career their
careers but throughout is that it's
about the plot
and the characters are just serving the
plot
and that's not not a good idea you want
the plot
to be servicing the characters in other
words
for instance aliens has a wonderful plot
but ripley is at the core she's the
heart of that movie and if that movie
were about people you didn't care about
that and that movie also by the way
introduces a wide variety of characters
incredibly well so if you look at when
they all wake up from the sleep pods and
you see you meet all of those characters
they're very different from each other
and they have their own take and they're
very
you get who they are really quickly and
there's a lot of them and so studying
that just saying okay how did that work
and uh
it works like a charm it's great it's
great and if you said so so because
ripley was not a flat character but if
some things have been slightly well if
if she were a flat character you
wouldn't care about that movie it would
just how many movies are based on aliens
were there where they're like big
science fiction movies and because the
characters are forgettable the movie is
forgettable you you don't you don't love
movies because of the plots generally
you love movies because of the
characters and uh you know and and i
think a lot of films are too clever for
their own good because they're they're
just twisting and turning the plot in
violation of the character and you never
want to do that because the moment the
audience distances from the character
you've lost them
and uh and you know i don't i don't like
puzzle boxes uh as as a structure i like
i mean you can have mystery you can have
revelations all of that that's fine but
i like to have characters who don't
you don't lose the characters because of
what the plot is doing you know and uh
so that's yeah and you don't throw them
away either you you respect your
character that doesn't mean they can't
die they can but uh
but you give what they do meaning you
know you never just you know you never
treat anyone as disposable and in my
opinion
and so with the dialogue knowing that
it's going to be distinct for each
character do you think a lot of new
writers start out thinking okay i'm
going to do sort of an aaron sorkinisk
sort of you know very talky it's
well also that's another mistake that
beginning writers make which is they're
they're they're talking talking talking
and talking
like get in and get out you know it's
like make your point and then
on to the next scene don't belabor it
you know so they they're they're much
too wordy and also yeah imitating
quentin tarantino imitating aaron sorkin
try not to you know i i i mean you know
sterling said when he started out he
everything he wrote was bad hemingway
and he said everything began it was hot
you know so you know and that's
forgivable in young people but again you
have to find your own voice you have to
find and the way to find your own voice
is what do i care about what do i know
about
what do i alone know what you know and
that it doesn't mean you can't write
things that are different from what
you've actually lived but what do you
know about and what do you care about
what gets you riled up and what's where
do you live emotionally and find and and
you know and then when and and if you
hear someone say something just in their
your your day i always carry a little
notepad with me and i jot things down
because if someone says a line that's
like wow that's great you know it's like
i'll you know i'll utilize that you know
and uh
and try not to rip off dialogue from
other movies because god it's so so many
people rip off lines from aliens it's
like oh please don't and uh you know so
that's part of it um
and and and don't bore if if something's
boring to you on the page it'll be
boring to everybody so
keep working on it until it works
and sometimes a scene doesn't work and
the only way to make it work is to get
rid of it and so be willing to do that
it's funny i was giving notes to someone
last week and they were saying well does
this character work i read their script
and gave them notes and it was a script
that had been developed at big companies
and uh he said there's this character
work i said no lose them they don't work
and i said and they're saying what about
this sequence no it doesn't work and i
said here's what your story is about
emotionally it's about a father and a
son and son doesn't think his father
loved him but in reality his father did
love him and shielded him and sacrificed
his own life but the son doesn't know
that and ultimately
our the son is willing to to do that for
his own daughter but the father's spirit
saves them you know this father comes
back as a spirit it's a fantasy film and
and once i said this is what your plot
is and everything else is distraction
and so don't
keep pulling it in this direction
pulling in the right direction follow
the emotional line
and uh because that'll work and so then
i just kind of took it
you know helped it along and again they
don't do they have to do my version of
their film no but they have to do a
version that works
and and if that if my version helps them
find their their path great
and uh because
many films don't know what they're
trying to
say or they have nothing to say you know
you know what what are most films about
most films are about two hours
so
you know it's like
know what you're trying to say and and
then remove the stuff that doesn't say
that
what's your favorite piece of dialogue
that you overheard personally that you
jotted in your little notebook yeah gosh
um
you know i
i don't remember and sorry about that
it's like
you know i i remember one of my favorite
lines that i ever wrote it's a terrible
line it's terrible they're in future
space which is about a future where we
trade our worst prisoners with
alien prisoners uh they
they breathe methane we breathe oxygen
they're the prison that's holding the
humans is on a methane world so we can't
escape they can't escape our prison here
on earth because it's oxygen they don't
breathe oxygen and it's about a
prison break that erupts at a um
at the handoff point a space station
between the two races and the aliens are
like eight foot tall jelly vertical
jellyfish they communicate via
chromatophores really fun and um and
we're gonna be doing that as a tv show
but the
uh
this guard who is like really sadistic
and at the end he saves one of our
characters and he dies and when he dies
he says i don't know why i did that and
and his boss the prison the head of the
pre the guard says
he was a prick but he had balls
it's such a stupid line
but it's like that's pretty good that's
funny yeah you know and again you know
you but again it has to be that
character who would say that line you
know and uh i think he was a dick but he
had balls whatever it is you know this
you know but again the reason that line
i like that line is because this is a
script that has rougher talking
characters you never have that line in
space command for instance which is much
more family show but fugitive space has
very rough language because it's
convicts and um
but it's about the industrial military
prison complex because ultimately two
prisoners one is a woman helicopter
pilot who's been framed for a wartime
massacre and the other is a former cop
who um
[Music]
killed his fellow officers because they
were going to murder a family he was a
dirty cop and that was the line he could
not cross but he killed them with
premeditation his brother officers and
so he's a trustee now in the prison but
a convict but they find out that the
earth government has struck a deal
with the aliens the aliens are fighting
a war that they're losing and so the
earth has struck a deal with them that
they can invade earth empty out all the
ghettos and use all the poor people to
fight in their war
basically as slave soldiers and so our
heroes have to get back to earth and
warn everybody and and and build a
counter insurgency so
so it's about something meaningful to me
uh which is the the people the
underclass the people who anything can
be done to them because they don't quote
unquote count
and i write about that thematically a
lot the people
that people need to be given respect
people need to be seen as human and as
as equal to us in every way and um so so
it's going to be a very interesting show
but um
but i created the characters who speak a
certain way so that line works in that
in that context but the hero doesn't say
that i just have this tough prison that
you know the boss of the prison guards
or charles derning i used charles
durning as a model for that guy and even
though charles durning is an older actor
who passed away but it's very vivid in
my head so that allows me to write him
so ah there you go but i've written
other lines you know but
you know it it depends you know on any
given day